si acaba de haber un giro radical en esa
operación de compra-venta de tweeter
como saben hasta ahora el consejo de
administración de la red social se
negaba a realizar esta venta pero acaban
de anunciar que se ha llegado a un
acuerdo y él lo más que el propietario
de tesla el hombre más rico del mundo
acaba de hacerse con la red social
'twitter' por 44 mil millones de dólares
eso equivale a unos 54 dólares por cada
acción según medios nacionales de aquí
de eeuu apuntan a que este cambio
radical de opinión ha llegado después de
un largo fin de semana de muchas
negociaciones que se han alargado hasta
la madrugada de este lunes en las que el
look más cara ha defendido el motivo por
el que él debía poseer esta red social
las ventajas y beneficios que tendrían
el 'wall street' el diario 'wall street'
apunta a que también ha sido posible
gracias a que los más se ha comprometido
a abordar todos los temas de libertad de
expresión que afectan ahora mismo a la
red social 'twitter' por supuesto
después de que el anuncio se haya hecho
público las acciones en bolsa de esta
empresa se han disparado